hey what's up guys welcome to my flutter
essential course and in this particular
course we are gonna talk about the
essential parts of flutter when you are
starting your journey with flutter so if
you're learning flutter so this is the
first course which I would recommend you
to take because there will be all the
essential things which you need when you
deal with flutter especially if you are
someone who has never worked with
flutter yet so this is definitely good
to go course for you and as you know
that the all the courses which are
available on empty barrel school they
are very short and concise courses which
means you will get the value out of it
without wasting your time so that's the
idea
so let's before we start the flutter
development then first of all we need to
install flutter so we will go to this
flutter dot dev website as you can see
flutter dot tail and once you go there
so this will be something like this you
will click on the get started button
which is on the right top so I'll click
here and as soon as I click here you
will see these kind of options like
Windows Mac OS or Linux you can select
any of them or depending on what
operating system you are using so I am
using Mac OS then I can just go here and
I can install the flutter version and
guys one more thing is that right now
what you will find here is this stable
version which is one point twelve point
thirteen hotfix seven so this is
something which you can use although I
am on the developer Channel so there are
developed channels master channel and
beta channel stable channel so there are
a lot of channels so every channel has a
purpose like master channel is the
latest one where you can also see a lot
of bugs because it's the latest one then
comes the develop arm channel which is
for developers and it has slightly less
bug then on the master Channel then
comes beta which is again better version
and then stable which is supposed to be
bug free so this is the
and here you will follow this guide I am
NOT gonna show you how to install
everything from scratch because that
will be a lot of time but you are open
to comment if you see any end of issues
and will definitely fix it out and then
for Windows also you need to make sure
that everything is like how it has been
explained here you can download either
the zip or you can maybe use git to
clone this particular repository and one
problem which happens with Windows user
a lot is that they forget to apply this
environment variable and then they see
that their flutter command is not
working so please make sure that you
follow the guide entirely and then you
can do something like you can go to your
terminal and you can try to run flutter
command and you will see these options
if you are not seeing them that means
the flutter is not working properly so
once you install it whether you are
using Windows Mac OS who bun to Linux or
whatever you can definitely go ahead and
then you can go to your console and then
what you have to write is rather than
just flutter if you aren't sure that you
have installed flutter properly then you
can run flutter doctor so what flutter
doctor will do for you so flutter doctor
is basically kind of a doctor which
which you normally understand right so
it will see all the things like
everything is proper or not and what you
are missing or what you are not missing
so as you can see my Android tool Chen
is ready Xcode is ready Chrome Android
studio I have two versions so that's why
to Emerald Studios IntelliJ IDEA vs code
and I have some connected devices as
well and you can see I am one channel
dev with version one point fifteen point
two but because I am doing lot of
experiments as well so that's why I am
using this channel you can use it but
then there can be some bugs so I suggest
you to be unstable only and guys one
more thing is that if you want to
develop for Android I would recommend
you to download Android studio as well
so that it will come with all the
necessary things so that there should be
some
the Android SDK manager there should be
the emulator and all that stuff so they
don't feel that kind of problem when you
are dealing with Android app development
and if you want to develop for iOS then
you need a Mac OS and then you also need
Xcode for that so that is something
which is important and for me I'm using
vs code but then also if you are gonna
use vs core then also I just say that
install Android studio because there is
no harm installing that because
sometimes it can be useful so we will
definitely talk about that in future as
well so now I am done with this part in
vs code if you are using vs code if you
are not using vs code then also I will
suggest you to use via score so that you
can get a better maybe build time
results and also better development
experience so once you are on vs code
you have to go to extensions and you
have to write flutter extension and you
have to install flutter extension from
here and then you can also install the
dart extension either of them will work
but it doesn't matter if you install
both of them then if you want snippets
then this rash lambda are snippets which
you can definitely use and this can be
pretty handy although you don't
necessarily need it and there are some
couple of other extensions like prettier
and get lens all those things which you
can use definitely you can check my vs
code video which I'll show you which
will be there in the notes and
definitely you can see what extension
you can use there now coming to the vs
cool we will press command shift P and
if you are on some other platform let's
say windows then you can replace
commands with control so control shift P
and first of all I am gonna change the
toggle mode and then I'm gonna write
flutter new project as you can see we
have a new project here and we can click
here and then we have to give the
project name okay so I'm gonna give it
awesome underscore app okay and I'm
gonna click enter I have to select my
folder and then this will create my
project okay so it will take some time
to create the project for me and as you
can see by default what we will get
our US language is swift and Android
languages Android X so I gotta lean so
and it is supporting Android X so that's
that's what we get and then we are also
gonna see how this structure is working
what what it all means and I'm gonna
just run this quickly so that you can
see what's actually happening with this
default application which you get and in
the meantime what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
I'm gonna show you something so I'm
gonna show you this by the time it's
running so as you can see I am on my
iPad and this is how the structure looks
like right as you can see here and I'm
gonna just explain what this means so
the first two is that dot dot tool and
dot idea you can ignore these tools and
I'm just gonna point them out with black
these we don't need actually or we can
just ignore it
then there is this Android folder which
contains all the Android code which
native Android developers usually write
and if you are like somehow related to
Android app development if you know
anything about that then you can
definitely check it out then there is
iOS folder which contains all is related
stuff and iOS developers can understand
that properly and then there's Lib
folder where we are gonna write all the
dart code and then there is Mac OS for
desktop support which we are gonna not
use and then there is test which is for
testing which we will definitely use in
one of our courses and then there is web
which contains index.html and all that
stuff which we again gonna see and
then what we are going to do we are
going to go back here with this one
second guys
so we can see this is what we get one
two three four five six seven eight this
is the counter application which we get
by default and then guys one thing also
I would like you to install is kit so if
we go to google and we will write kit
then the first link which you will get
you have to download this so this is a
version control system which will help
you in keeping your code up to date as
well as you can check what you have done
in history you can create multiple
branches or all that stuff and as I told
you this is just not about flutter there
are many other things which we will
learn during this particular course or
in other courses as well so these are
the things which are actually very
useful for developers when doing real
world development so definitely I would
suggest to do download this and then we
will set up get in next video as well
and then we will see this home page
properly in the next video
so guys this is what we have got this is
the counter application which we have
got so now again talking about these
folders let me just show you what we are
getting here so Android as I told you
there will be all the Android related
code which you might be familiar or not
and similarly for iOS and then in the
lip we will keep all our dart files so
basically this is where we are gonna
work
then Mac OS is again the same thing like
iOS and the test which will have all the
testing files and for web as you can see
there is index dot HTML and all those
files and another important file for us
is pub spec dot e ml where we will keep
all the dependencies so whatever
third-party library or plugin we want to
use we are going to use it here ok now
moving ahead this is something which we
have and now what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
open my terminal by pressing command J
so I am gonna just say toggle screencast
mode and then if you will press command
J or you can press ctrl J in Windows and
for specifically terminal you can press
control and tilt so that it will open
the terminal and here you can write gate
and in it so basically the purpose of
this is creating a local git repository
which will track all of your changes so
as you will see here this is my version
control symbol if I will click here then
you can see these are all the changes
which are needed to be committed so I
will commit these changes by writing
here a message initial commit which
means I am saving it technically to my
local repository and then I can push it
to my online repository if I want so
this is something which is very
important because maybe if you want to
go back and see what you have done or
maybe you want to keep track of your
code then this is actually very
important now as you can see we are here
on the master branch I'm going to change
the branch and I'm gonna name it dev
hashtags
- one which is chapter one this will
help us in keeping the track of all the
chapters which we are gonna cover and in
each chapter there will be some specific
or detail like there will be for one
chapter for networking one chapter for
sheer preferences and one for layout
design and all that stuff okay now
concentrating on this particular part as
you can see we have this default
application which is not very friendly
at least to understand what actually is
happening so I'm gonna delete all this
code and what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
write void main which you might be
familiar with already right so wide main
is from where everything starts is like
similar to what you might have done in
your any other object-oriented
programming language and we can see we
got some error then there is this one
method here in floater which we call run
app it acts accepts and particular
application so if you see here it takes
a widget so be a writer it cannot
understand it so basically it takes
three kinds of application which you can
give let's say first one will be widgets
app second can be um you can say
material app okay so we can say material
app and third can be Cooper to you app
okay so the difference between them is
I'm gonna just show you so if what I do
I can import from here widgets dot dot
so this will give us widgets app so I
can also show you so this run app if you
will see here that it takes an app which
is again a widget so everything in
flutter is a widget and end of widget is
a component and for example this is the
phone you can see everything here like
this Sunday Feb 9 is also a widget these
buttons is or also the widget especially
this google search bar is a kind of a
widget and these all icons in a row is
of widget itself so everything is a
widget
flutter so if we go back to our
application here we can write widgets
app so widgets app will work the only
problem with widgets app is that it's a
little bit low level which means that it
will not provide you in build design
support by itself for that you can use
something like a material package so we
can use material flutter slash material
dot dot and rather than this visits app
we can use material app ok and let's say
if you are fan of human interface design
which is in iOS or Mac OS so what we can
do we can also import this is Cupertino
dot dot and rather than material app we
can write Q Patino app q Pertino app and
this is something which you might have
seen in whatsapp that it's Android
application is little difficult or
different than its iris application
which I don't know if you have seen it
but yes that's that's what people do
sometimes as a brand then they show
different kind of UI depending on the
operating system so that's also you can
do but for the simplicity and for a
universal design we are gonna use
material dot dot at least for now
and then in future we will also discuss
the Q part you know design so I'm gonna
use your material app and then I'm gonna
use something like you can say here we
have few properties like home so I'm
gonna give it a home widget which is
let's say a container itself so a
container with a color so color so what
is what this material is giving is
giving us is like there's a lot of
widget which it gives and then it gives
us a colors library which we can use to
import any of this color here so I can
say like let's say I want to use a
purple color so I can just search here
and a lot of colors so I can right
purple purple so as you can see now
nothing is reflected here because we
have two buttons here which are very
important one is this the flash button
which is hot reload and then this green
button which is hot restart so whenever
you do some changes in material app and
if that is a part of run app then you
have to do a hot restart and then we can
see the changes that everything is
purple not right and then what I'm gonna
do here I'm gonna give it a child as
well so child let's say and the child
can be a text widget okay so a text and
then I can show some say something like
hi flutter and you will see here that
there should be some flutter but it is
it's like somewhere invisible or we are
not able to see it anywhere and that's
the problem with this so we need to say
what color it is and we need to specify
it more so right now it will it will not
reflect because we haven't done hot
restart as well so that also we need to
do so once I will do hot restart then
you will see high flutter on the screen
the problem is that it is not looking
very great and you might have heard me
saying that material package if we will
use then it will give us better design
but it's not looking good so what we can
do we can create a new widget from here
which is a stateless widget so if you
will write STL then it will give you a
shortcut to write this visit let's say
homepage okay and we are gonna copy this
container code from here and we will
paste it here and everywhere you need to
see that it will either extend stateless
widget or stateful widget I show you the
difference what is the difference
between them then it will also override
a build method so this extends means
that it is inherited something so it's
like parent and child relationship
so you are as a child must have
inherited few things from your parents
so that is like this home page is also
inheriting this build method from its
parent and then some other things as
well and overriding it means that
whatever they have provided you will
overwrite it with your own like they
have given you of all it is some kind of
you know think that every parent will
give their child a wallet and then they
can override it that what they want to
enter in that wallet or what they want
to keep in that wallet so that's up to
you so this is the same thing we have
done now rather than this container we
will call it home page and once we do
that and though as you can see now if I
do a hot restart everything will be
remaining the same but this time if I
will change it to high flutter to high
flutter app then you will see we can see
the changes quickly as soon as I press
command S or I as soon as I press this
hot reload so once you are out of this
run app method then hot reload will
start working so that's also what you
can do and now it's again still not
looking so convincing so we are gonna
use another widget which we can call ski
fold so scaphoid is basically kind of a
structure which has some basic widgets
like an app bar so app bar if you will
over here then it will show you that it
takes a preferred size widget which can
be a bar itself
so a bar widget we can use then it has
many properties as you can see and we
are going to use title property and as
you can see on the right hand side our
app is looking much better now and then
we can say text and here I can say let's
say awesome app and as you can see this
is looking much much better now I want
to change its color from blue to
something like a purple so inside this
material app we will come back and here
there is something called theme and
which takes a theme data so I'm gonna
select it and I'm gonna say
that I want that theme data and inside
that there is many properties like
brightness font family canvas color
accent color card color and lot more
things I'm going to use primary swatch
which is a collection of colors which we
can use so let's say if I say colors dot
red if I give red color then it will
take some combination of colors
depending on red and it will give it to
entire application so I'm gonna say here
purple which means it will give purple
to all my colors like purple as a
primary color and other colors which is
which suits best with purple and now I'm
gonna do hot restart because I am doing
changes inside the run app method so you
need to do hot restart and now you can
see we got purple which is looking much
better and now in the body part of it
we can use the same container which we
were using earlier soap container and in
the child we can say text and inside the
text we can say hi flutter so as soon as
I will say it you can see hi flutter
here and this is looking great right so
in the next video we will talk about
more widgets and what are the
differences between them how to use
these widgets and where to use which
widget so see
hey guys so now we are gonna see other
things as well like we have seen how to
create our application what is what are
like themes which are available or
colors which are available as well as we
saw is K fold and this stateless widget
so stateless widget is something which
is not supposed to change which means
whatever you are seeing on screen let's
say you are seeing this high floater
so this is always going to be high float
or it's not going to change which means
it's stateless so any widget there is
many components which you will see in
particular series and every kind of
component is of widget as I already told
you now before proceeding guys we are
gonna commit this changes that our
chapter 1 is completed you can write
something like this and then I'm gonna
press this right key done key to commit
this and then I'm gonna go here and I'm
gonna create a new branch which I'm
gonna say dev hashtag CH 2 which means
chapter 2 so these these are some
chapters which just for tracking so you
can definitely visit this github
repository and then you can see the
branches to understand it once you are
watching this course on my school so
this is what you have to do now guys we
will explore more widgets and now on the
most powerful widget which we are going
to explore is container itself so
container is kind of you can say a box
so if you are familiar with HTML then
it's something which is very similar to
div so this is what we have here in
caress container so inside this body
part you can see this container right so
now we are gonna play with it and we
will let's see what we can do with this
so I'm gonna just remove this child as
of now and then um we are gonna give
some color to this container so let's
give it a color let's say red so color
start red and as you can see this time
it is taking the entire screen
and that's not something which I want I
want a box here okay a small box so what
I can do I can give a width to it let's
say 100 pixels so it's a density pixel
which is DP and similarly we will give
it a height of 100 and then you can see
we have a box here right and the red
color box now we wanted to be in the
center so we can use another widget here
which we can just so you will come to
this container and you will press
command dot or control dot or you can
also press this bulb here which you will
see in vs code and if you are using
Android studio then you can press alt
enter so if I'll click here then there
are many options like rap with widget
rap with center rap with column so
either you can use rap with widget and
then you can write Center or you can
directly wrap it with Center and now if
I'll save it then you can see in the
center of this screen this is the box
and similarly it has many other features
which we get from container so now I'm
gonna also write the child again and
this time I'm gonna say I am a box so
now you can see we have I am a box now
it is like very much touching the corner
of the container so I don't want that
for that I have some other properties of
containers which has this padding so
padding means that it will cue it will
compress that widget and it will provide
some space so there is there are two
properties one is margin and one is
padding margin means just left and right
or top or bottom adjustment what padding
means is compressing them so you'll see
the difference itself so if you will use
padding then it will work in this case
for I am a box or text and if you'll use
March and then it won't work so for
padding if you see what it takes it
takes our edge inserts geometry so I'm
gonna use a constant as in sets and then
it has many properties or many methods
I should say so these are the methods
like all to give that padding to entire
corners let's say left right top bottom
from every year and only which means
that for specific let's say just for
left symmetric which means horizontal or
vertical and era TRB which means left
top right bottom so anything you can
decide so I'm gonna select all and I'm
gonna give a padding of 8 and now you
will see that I am a box got some
padding right and if if I would have
used margin here then you might have
seen no difference and that's because
margin is just for adjustment between
those components so that's the
difference so padding we are gonna use
now there are other properties as you
can see your alignment
okay so alignment means where you want
to place this child okay where you want
to align it so we can use something
called alignment dot let's say we want
to show it in the center then you will
see I am a box in the center and let's
say if you want to see it in the bottom
right then you can just say bottom right
and you will see it here in the bottom
right so this is the purpose of
alignment there are a lot of enums which
you can use bottom right bottom left top
left top right so let's say top left so
you see it in the top left so these are
the things which you can do then is you
might be wondering what is this child so
every container or everything has either
one child or many children so basically
if you say that is one component so
let's say row okay so row is basically
there will be so if you are making a row
there will be one element or more than
one so in that case there will always be
children let's say list view row column
and like these kind of visits where it
is container sized box or so small small
components which can have only one side
so then you will use child so I'm going
to explain it more in the future as well
so don't worry if you don't understand
something and then the most important
property of contain
which is gonna be very useful for you is
one is constraints which which is kind
of not very useful until unless you go
into deep like UI designs otherwise the
most important which I'm going to talk
about his decoration by which you can do
a lot of things with this container you
can provide gradients you can give
shapes you can give images whatever you
want to do so this decoration takes a
box decoration so box decoration I'm
gonna say and now you can see it has
many properties like image color and
gradient and all that stuff now there is
some error and the error is saying that
something related to color and the
problem is guys so one you once you want
to decorate something which means you
have already given it color okay and
this box decoration also have a color
property as you can see so these will
clash so either you can give a color
here or you can use a box decoration so
because we are using box decoration so
I'm gonna remove this color from here
and the error will be gone but we are
losing our color so we will come here
inside this box decoration we will data
will give the color and now the error is
also gone and we also caught our color
back now if we have a lot of other
things like we can give a border radius
we can give a shape so for shape it
takes a box shape so we can say box
shape dot circle or rectangle so we can
select circle and you see we will see
this kind of circle and it is going
beyond here like the circle and the text
is text is not exactly inside the circle
so container has some clip behavior as
well so how you want to clip it so you
can say clip hard-edged non anti-alias
so make sure you are using anti-alias so
that you will not see that part of like
now you can see the text is not here
outside this particular container so
that's what you can do there is more
options like none which means you will
see the text and then
there is anti ellyas with same layer
which is kind of expensive so I will say
again not to use it and then there is
hard edge so just ignore them you can
just use any alias in most of the cases
to get your shapes properly so I'm gonna
just remove it right now
and rather than this shape dot circle we
want to give some rounded corners right
so it's it's like there is no corner
this is this hard edge corner so rounded
corner we can use border radius and we
can say border radius dot border radius
dot circular and let's give a radius of
10 from all the sides and now you can
see we have our border radius and this
is looking much better right and then
guys um we can also give shadow to this
so for that you can see we have like you
can give border as well you can give box
shadows so for box shadow it takes an
array so we can say box shadow and then
we can say color so I want to use gray
color and then we can give a blur radius
let's say 5 so now you will see
something like a shadow here as you can
see there is slight shadow if I increase
the blur radius to 10 then you will see
uhm better version of it of this shadow
now similarly as I told you you can
apply gradients so ok or if I go to this
pillow border radius then there is
something called gradient there can be
many kind of gradient like linear
gradient radial gradient sweep gradient
so I'm gonna use linear gradient because
that's what we are gonna use most of the
time it asks for colors or begin or
stops point so I'm gonna give it some
colors so first color let's say we will
give it something like a pink and oh
it's looking so bad because at least we
need two colors and second colors I'm
gonna give it something like a yellow
maybe let's try this and now and you can
see this is how a gradient will look
like right and just looking so good
right and now guys I'm going to
plain let's do one thing let's put this
text in the center so we will use this
alignment to Center it and it's looking
much better and now we will move to this
text so this text is again a very
important widget because everywhere you
are gonna use text so you should know
all its properties so it has many
properties like you can align the text
you can give how many lines this text
can take what is soft wrap what what you
want to do for overflow cases but most
important is this style which we are
going to use it takes a Texas style so
everything is here inside this text I
like font size font family and the font
weight so I'm gonna give it a font size
of 20 let's say and as soon as I will
give it 20 you can see it goes like this
I want to Center them still
so there is a text property which is
text aligned I'm gonna use them and I
can say text align dot Center and you
will see the box I am a box is now in
center now if you want you can also
change the color of the text so let's
say I'm gonna say color star to white so
I can give it white and then you can see
this is the white color now I want to
make it bold so I can say font weight
dot bold and use commas to just move it
to the next line
so that looks good now it is boiled as
well so yeah these are some of the most
common kind of you know you can use
letters Heights and you know decoration
also like you want to have underline in
this particular text word spacing so lot
of other stuff but these are some common
ones which I just showed you and in the
next video I'm going to talk about most
important to widgets like these and
let's see in the next
hey guys so we have seen container which
is kind of a very useful widget or text
as well
now moving ahead let's talk about some
more widgets and we will see what else
can be very useful for us and what else
we should definitely consider using so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna first of all
remove these bulky container like this
decoration I don't want right now so I'm
will remove it even I will remove the
child as well so let's remove all of
this so that it can be very simple and
then we will give it back the color and
so we can say color start red and it
looks good now I'm also gonna remove
this Center from this so remove this
widget or if you want you can just place
it like this so it's totally your call
so let's place it as of now we will then
remove it there is this container but
let's say I want three containers in a
row so how I will place this I so as you
can see the center can have only one
child so how I will have three child so
basically for that we can use something
called a [ __ ] of a row or a column so
because we want to place it horizontally
so we will use a row here and as you can
see it takes children rather than a
child because it can have one or maybe
more than one elements or maybe zero
it's totally your calls so first we will
have this container which I just copied
and paste it and by default it came to
this you know left hand side and then I
will have second container which will
come to right of it and then I will have
third container which will go again on
the other side and then I'm gonna just
change the color of second to yellow and
too green to differentiate between them
so that you can understand row properly
and it looks like a traffic light but
yeah it's looking very ugly although so
that is what we have got now now what if
you want it to be placed in the center
right solo has a property a very good
property which we can say main axis
alignment four row so if it is a row the
main axis would be the horizontal axis
as you can see this cursor is dragging
in the horizontal so this is its main
axis and then the cross axis will be the
vertical axis okay so this vertical axis
is cross axis for row and main axis is
this horizontal axis but for column the
main axis is the vertical axis and the
cross axis the horizontal axis so that
is the difference so now I'm gonna say
like say that main axis alignment dot
Center to Center these elements and it
looks good now you can tell me that I
just want red on the left-hand side to
the corner and right hand side I want
the green one so you can just replace
Center with space between and you will
see the difference that this is on the
left hand side this is on the right hand
side and now you might say that okay it
is touching the corner I just don't want
to touch the corner a little bit of
space from here so in that case you can
use something called space around which
will give a little space from here but
then you will see that this space is not
evenly mapped with this space right in
that case you can use something called
space evenly which will distribute them
with like equal spaces as you can see
this is space and this space is kind of
same right so these are the things which
you can do with this and then if you
want there is start and so if you want
to push it into the end so this is also
you can do so now I'm gonna go with
space evenly which looks good to me
and because we have used this Center on
in the top of this particular widget
tree so which means that's why it is in
center if I will remove this from here
it will go on the top so as we can see
here because this is the area which it
is taking right so
this will only take this space which it
needs and then there is another property
which is cross X this alignment like on
the cross axis as I told you this will
be the vertical axis for Rho so you can
say cross axis alignment dot Center then
it will take it to the center but
because this is just a container so what
I'll do
I'd also wrap this row with another
widget which is a container widget and
this time I will give it a color okay so
this container has a color let's say and
I'm gonna say it color start peel just
for the sake of giving it a color and
you can see the container is taking teal
color and that size of it is very much
limited to these boxes okay so that's
why the center of cross axis alignment
is depending on this container if I
let's say if I give it a height let's
say 500 then you will see now the
container is like 500 height but this
cross axis alignment dot Center is
working which means if these boxes are
in the center right if I change this
this time from center to let's say start
then it will go on the top again and if
I will say and then it will come on the
last portion of it right and similarly
we can do changes with the main axis
alignment that's what we do right so
these are the things again guys very
important and then we will go back to
Center let's say and now what I want to
do I want to stretch them so if I say
stretch then it will take the entire
column right so this is what you can do
now let's go back to Center and now
replace this row with column and you
will see the same things but the
difference is that now it's a column so
main axis alignment is actually the
vertical alignment and cross axis
alignment is actually the this
horizontal alignment so now because we
are giving height to 500 it took the and
tire height but actually it does not
care about the width so height is 500
but width is not 500 because it's a
column okay so there is also one
property that main exercise what you
want the main exercise to be so either
it can be minimum or maximum so but this
maximum again depends on the parent that
what parent provides to the maximum size
so as we know the container is not
providing any maximum size we can
definitely have constraints there but
right now it's actually minimum so now
rather than height if let's say I say
width then you will see that it takes
entire width entire height and width 500
width or whatever width you wanna say
let's say 300 then you will see it takes
300 and main exercise is spaced evenly
which means the vertical alignment is
spaced evenly if I will change it to
space between then you will see it will
go to the corner of vertical alignment
and then cross axis alignment it is
actually now row or you can say
horizontally whatever you can see now if
I will say stretch then it will stretch
horizontally and that's the difference
between rows and columns so these are
very powerful and very important widgets
which you are going to use everywhere so
please keep in mind that this is
something which we are going to use a
lot in the next video we'll talk about
drawer and floating action buttons and
all that stuff so
we have actually covered a lot so far
and if you will see now we have now this
joint container with so many you know
components inside it like so many
containers and this is looking very ugly
to be honest so I'm just gonna give it
again row and then I'm gonna give it a
height which can be again hundred and we
don't actually care a lot about it and
so that's why we are gonna finish this
chapter with these columns and rows so
I'm gonna go here and I can say chapter
two completed and now we will start
chapter 3 where we will talk about
drawer and how to create beautiful
designs so I'm gonna come here and I'm
gonna create a new branch I'm gonna call
it Deb hashtag ch3 and this is our
chapter number three now on guys I'm
actually going to remove this child from
here because it's actually looking very
bad and I'm happy with this thing with
hundred and let's wrap it in the center
now let's talk about how we can have a
drawer here okay and also a floating
action button so first of all let's
cover the floating action button because
that is very easy to do in flutter so
here after body because I told you that
escape fold provides you an entire
structure it has which has a lot of
components and that's what we are gonna
see so we have seen app bar we have seen
body and if you'll see there are lot
more widgets so we are going to use
floating action button and it takes a
visit so what widget would be best for
it that will be again a floating action
button itself so floating action button
as you can see now we have a floating
action button here okay and it came
within a named animation which looks
good now every button in float or needs
to be implemented its own pressed which
means that if that's a button definitely
you are gonna press on it if you are not
gonna press on it then it should not be
a button right so by default it is null
but we can do
like it's it takes a void function so we
can have two braces like this with the
brackets as well so which means it's an
empty implementation we will do
something in future okay and then it
takes a child so first side you can say
I'm gonna give it an icon so icon is
again a widget and similarly to colors
we have icons library from which we can
pick any material design icon let's say
I'm gonna use edit and you can see this
has taken the color to white itself
I haven't specified but flauta
understands the size and color as well
so most of the widgets understand what
kind of child they want and what should
be the size and color of it so this is
the floating action button now again
there are other properties like how much
elevation you want to give what should
be the background color what should be
the shape hero tag and if you want this
you know button to be a little smaller
than you can say min equal to true and
then it will be smaller but usually it's
a normal so we will remove this property
and all we can do it let me get false
autofocus horror color so these are the
few things which maybe you will use with
flutter for web but right now we don't
need it so I'm gonna remove it then also
guys there is one more property for
floating action button which is its
location and there's one animator as
well but that's we are not gonna use
right now but floating button location
we can use floating button location dot
what location you want to use if you
want to attach it with center with a
bottom bar or something it will come
here and it will be attached but if you
want to make it little flow tables so it
will not attached to any bottom bar and
it will float it will have some margin
and then similarly you can do it for
let's say if you want on the top so it
will say start top it will go on the top
and similarly you can maybe end out and
float so it will go again
the same place so for the simplicity and
for the betterment of design I'm gonna
remove it again this was just to explain
you now we are gonna quickly make a
drawer and how difficult it can be so
with the body there is another property
which we can say listen trawl and it
takes a widget which is again a very
interesting widget and the name is draw
so yeah that's that's only what you have
to do now we have a drawer and if we
click on it we see this white screen
which is I don't know what kind of
screen it is it's it's it's it's having
nothing ok now we are gonna make a very
good drawer so inside this drawer you
will see what properties it takes
so it has elevation semantic label child
so we are gonna use this child and guys
um as you will see that with every
widget you will see this property which
is this key property so you can specify
keys to every widget it's totally your
choice and there can be many kinds of
keys let's say local key unique key
object key the purpose of keys is that
it helps the framework mom in
understanding that what widgets are
needs to be again repainted or redrawn
so it helps that if you don't provide a
key then framework itself provides a key
to these widgets and it helps it in
actually redrawing everything so right
now we are not gonna discuss it but in
future we will definitely focus on keys
and how to use them in some other course
so because it's just essential so you
probably don't need it right now
so in drawer there is something called
child and here we are going to use a
list view and in the future videos we
will talk about list view dot builder
which is kind of a recycler view you can
say we will also recycle the elements
but right now we just want to use a list
view and inside the list view we again
have a children because as you as I told
you that list view column rules must
have children's so now in this list view
the first thing which I want is some
kind of a draw
a header so draw header is definitely a
widget hill it takes a child and in the
child I can say text hi
I am a drawer and yes we got the wrong
guys it's looking good not the best but
yes it's looking fine and okay that's
that's what we have right we can also
give it some kind of decoration so I'm
gonna use a box decoration and then I
can give it a color so let's say I'm
gonna give it same color let's say
purple and guys it's looking good but
you know there is this problem that the
upper part of it is having this gray
background because the list view by
default gives some padding so we want to
remove that padding so we will use this
padding and we will say cause agent sets
dot all and we will give the padding to
zero and now you will see this is
looking much better right so now we have
the drawer ready now we want some items
so hey here after drawer because it's it
takes children so we can have other
elements our other visits so another
very useful widget with list view is
list tile so we are gonna use list style
so list style gives us lot of things
like it gives a leading property where
we can have something on the left hand
side of this particular portion so we
can use something let's say an icon and
icons dot person then you will see we
have icon on the left hand side is
looking very good now there is one more
property called title we can give it a
title so let's say text and I'll give it
my name let's say Pawan Kumar and now we
have a title as well and we can have a
subtitle as well guys so for subtitle we
can say let's say developer and yes we
have a subtitle but then we have a
trailing icon as well or trailing widget
as well and everything takes a wizard so
it's not like you have to
give it an icon you can give anything
here or text or whatever but I am gonna
give it an icon and this time I'm gonna
give it let's say edit icon so an edit
icon is added here and this is looking
very good I'm gonna just copy it I'm
gonna paste it so another here and this
time I will replace it with email and
I'm gonna say Pawan Kumar um I will say
email and I can say / one or maybe MTAC
viral antedate gmail.com so these are
the things which you can do and this
time now our dry draw looks good but is
slightly one improvement we can do this
drawer header is not looking so good and
if you have seen Gmail the draw looked
good with the picture as well and lot of
other details so we can definitely do
that here as well so what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna remove this floor header there
is something called user account drawer
header which we are gonna use and it is
basically for applications like Gmail
where you can say account name account
email so for account name you can say it
takes a visit so we can give it a widget
let's say text and I can again say Pawan
Kumar and you will see Pawan Kumar is
coming we haven't specified the location
but it knows where it should show it and
then for the count email again
text and I'm gonna just say M Tech where
L at the read gmail.com it looks good
right really good now I also want to add
a picture so I can have this current
account picture which looks good and the
current Upshaw account picture takes a
widget so I can use guys something like
so first of all I'll go to Google I'll
go to unsplash.com from here I can get
some free images so I'm gonna say a guy
or guy let's say
any random guy we can take and we can
take his picture so let's copy the let's
open this image in a new tab and copy
the address and guys this time I'm gonna
use something called an image widget and
dot then there is more methods to it
like asset if you are using an image
from your folder or application inside
your app our file if you want to use
your phone and you want to access a file
the network if you want to download it
from some network from a URL and memory
if you want to take it from the memory
so we want to use it from network so we
will use network and I will paste the
URL here and you will see we have this
image here right this is looking good
but it would look much better if we will
use it in a circular component right or
widget so I'm gonna just remove this and
I'm gonna use a circle avatar okay and
actually circle avatar has a child where
I can actually use the same image but
circle avatar if we will provide even
the child then also it will not give a
circular image
why because circle of TOD does not work
like that
but definitely it has something to offer
and that something is I'm just gonna
show you so we got the circle there is
one more property which is background
image there is radius foreground color
and all that but we want to use this
background image which which takes an
image provider so like we we saw the
image widget which has methods like
asset network similarly we have image
providers let's say asset image okay and
network image so these are the image
providers which we can use and here now
if I will paste this URL then you will
see a circular image here and this is
looking much better alright so now we
have a full-fledged or drawer which
looks kind of really good and especially
we can add more things like on details
pressed other account picture
and even if you want to tap on this list
of tiles then there is an on tap
property which you can definitely use
and once you click here you can perform
some operations so that's also you can
use so if you click here you can see we
got some ripple effect but with email
because we haven't implemented on tap
that we don't get any effect so yeah
this this is the floating action button
and drawer in the next video we will
talk about more images like how we can
access images from our application we
will also talk about text fields and
other things in the next
hey guys so we have implemented the
troll which is looking very nice and
also we have the floating action button
but this homescreen this body part is
looking very very bad and then we want
to you know try to add something else
here and let's see what we can do with
this part also we are gonna cover the
stateful widget which we haven't covered
yet so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go
back to this particular screen I'm gonna
search coding and I'm gonna like have
any image from here or there and I'm
gonna just paste it here so you can
download any image and you can paste it
so I have already one image so in this
particular root directory I'm going to
create a new folder as you can see in
this test is basically giving me some
error that there is no my app so I'm
gonna replace it with home page so that
it just not give me any kind of error
and I want to import this so I can just
say command dot again it's it's not
going to take it because there is
something wrong with this okay so we
just remove that problem and now now we
want to create a new folder for images
so I'm gonna say a new folder and I'm
going to name it assets so assets so you
can see this is my new folder assets it
is blank now I am going to this pops
back dot y ml but before that let's add
some image here so what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna take one image I'm gonna drop it
here so this is BG dot jpg this is one
image and now we have to tell our
application that there are images in one
folder so now we will go to our pop
SPECT or tml and here you will see we
have all the dependencies like you
Pertino icons some dev dependencies
saying that uses materialize or design
which is true and here we have some
commented
which is assets we are gonna just
uncomment it and for assets
it is using images folder but you can
use any name but I am using assets so
I'm gonna say assets and then slash and
I'm gonna remove everything which means
that every image inside the asset folder
we want to use that so we have just one
image but this slash means all the
images or all the assets inside your
assets folder so that's being done now
coming back to main dot dot what I'm
gonna do I am just going to remove this
Center and container and if you want you
can just keep that Center just remove
the container and we are going to talk
about another widget which is a card
widget which we will see a lot so I can
use a card widget so the purpose of card
visit is having a card right which can
have elevation and all that and right
now you can see that there is no card
which is visible and also I want to
change the background color of this
escape fold so escape word has a
property called background color and
let's give it a crash color gray of 200
so you can also specify the number here
to give a slightly you know different
variant of that color and now we have
this card and now card also have
elevation shape clip behavior and all
that property I'm gonna use child and
guys I'm gonna use a column here why
because you know in column I can have
many elements vertically aligned so it
takes a children so first element I want
is image dot asset this time I'm not
going to face the image from network but
from asset which means from my folders
and I just pasted one image here and the
name of this image is in first of all it
is inside assets so assets slash and now
we have to give the image name which is
BG dot jpg and now this is the image
which we can see okay and similarly if
let's say you want to specify if
this image how it fits what is the width
and height you can definitely do that
let's say if width is hundred so you can
see the width is there but it's looking
very ugly that's the different thing and
if you want to give some height let's
say 100 then also you can see we have
this width and height now there is one
more property fit and you can give box
fit so whether it is contained cover so
if I say contain then you will see
there's no such difference right now but
you'll see some differences in different
aspect ratios but if I say fill then you
will see it will fill it it will
basically stretch it so there will be no
gaps and covers contain or cover looks
almost the same in this particular image
only it's not the same although so cover
is like it will cover it but it will not
stretch it right so that's that's a good
thing so cover is mostly the best option
or maybe content fit width then it will
fit the width and if well say fit hide
then it will fit the height and yeah
that's those are the things which you
can do so right now I'm just gonna
remove all of them and it it looks like
this very nice okay and this is the
image which we have now and one thing is
that I still can see the card but it's
not looking that great if you see we
have a card here which is taking the
entire screen okay so what I'm gonna do
on this card I'm gonna wrap it with
padding I'm gonna give some padding
let's see 16 so that at least we can see
the card and now we can see the card
it's looking good and then I'm going to
talk about another widget which is a
sized box widget so size box widget is
what guys it can use to have a box a
particular box with some size okay and
if you don't want to have anything then
you can also use it for spacing padding
also can be used but padding looks a
little bit uglier because it
you need to rap with it but sighs box is
very clean and here you can just say
height let's say 20 pixels so it will
give a height after image and then we
can have a text let's see text and I can
say change my name here so very simple
example change my name and we are gonna
change this name okay so that's I change
my name we can give some styling here
let's say textile we can give a font
size let's say our 25 something like
that it looks good
let's give it a font weight as bold okay
this is looking good now guys there is
one more thing which we can we are going
to use and that is a text field so text
field is an edit text where we can press
a break where we can enter some text so
text field is here I'm gonna use that
and text will also have many properties
like controller which can be used to
control this text field then where there
is style again textile and all that
things which we have already seen then
the keyboard type like what kind of
keyboard you want you want text email or
number keyboard so all of those things
you can specify then auto correct auto
focus on tap on some meter cursor color
so lot of properties we are going to use
decoration but this time it is not
taking input decoration but it is or
sorry it's not taking box decoration but
it is taking input decoration so we are
going to use input decoration and inside
the input decoration there is boarder
and all that stuff you can specify but
first I want to specify hint text now
this is not taking a text widget but it
is just taking a string so I can say
enter some text okay and it's looking
good right it's looking really nice and
I want to give it a material design feel
so I'm gonna say something like what
else I'm gonna give it a label as well
so label text we can say name so now if
you will click here you can see this is
looking good right and guys one one more
thing we can do here is so we can do
some padding as well right
so with this text and we want some
distance between them as well so we will
use size box to give some more distance
and then we will give the padding as
well so we can have some padding like
eight and maybe 16 in fact it will look
much better yes it looks much better and
now if I click here you can see some
overflow pixel issues which means if my
keyboard is coming up this text here it
can not move upwards which means if it
was scrollable then it could move upward
and as you can see our floating action
button is also moving upward so that
could be better but before that we can
also give one more design to it so there
is a border property as well so for
border we can give it outline border
outline input border which will make it
look much more better yeah it's looking
much better but we want to get rid of
this particular you know problem which
is this overflow so we can go to this
column or we can in fact go to this
entire card and we can wrap it with
another widget which is single child
scroll view which means it's a scroll
view which can be scrollable and it can
have just one single child and now we
are having this scroll view if I click
here then it just goes on the up side
right and it is crawling but it's not
giving that error anymore and our card
size is also now making more sense so
yeah single child scroll view for
scrolling and now what I want whatever
data I write here okay if I press this
button this button this edit button let
me just change it the icon to let's say
something like sand and if I just click
here then this change my name text
should change okay so basically right
now if you will see my home page then
it's a stateless widget
right so stateless widget as I told you
is not supposed to change in it's an
entire lifetime so we need to first of
all convert it to a stateful widget so
basically we want to change this change
my name depending on this text field now
this text field is itself or stateful
widget why because every time you write
something here
things change right so whenever there is
some change then you need to make sure
that that's a stateful digit so if you
will go inside text field if you'll
press command click or f12 then you will
see that text field widget is extending
a stateful widget so that is the thing
so now how we can convert this home page
to a stateless widget we can click on
this bulb here and it will say convert
class to a mixin or converted straight
full widget I'm gonna click here and it
will convert it so now we will have two
classes basically one is homepage which
extends stateful widget and then another
is homepage state which extends state
and we will work with this state state
is like what is the like current
situation of this particular page so
like if you are a human if you are a
person what can be your state whether
you are sitting where you are walking
whether you are doing something that is
your state so everything on the UI is a
state so now um what I'm gonna do guys I
am going to have first of all my text so
my text by default um it's name is
change my name let's say and I'm going
to replace this change my name with this
my text so my text and now you can see
it has this capital letters so that
means this change my name is walking now
I want to need a controller for this
text field so I can say a text editing
controller name controller let's say if
I use this underscore which means it's a
private field so name controller and
equal to new text editing controller so
as you know in dot - you don't have to
right this new keyword so if I am
writing this then also it means the same
thing if I remove it then also it means
the same thing and now I can use this
name controller with this text field so
there is some controller and I can say
name controller okay and now what I want
guys is that actually we can go here to
this floating action button and on the
press of it what we can do we can change
my text which is the text to change my
name equal to and we can give it the
text of the controller or the text field
so name controller dot text so if I now
write something here let's say that my
name is Pawan so now if I press this
button then it should reflect but it
does not reflect it right but if I do a
hot reload then you will see that Pawan
is of like reflected why this happened
because whenever there will be some
change let's say now if I replace it
with something else let's say I place it
with Rohit so now even if I will press
this button then nothing will actually
happen so why does that is not working
because in flat or every time you do a
state change every time you want to
change your UI then you have to call a
method called set state and if I do that
then you will see Rohit here now if I
change this text to something like this
random and if I press this button now
then you will see it will directly
reflected so this is how you deal with
text field this is how you make a card
this is how you make a stateful widget
and that's how it works and now this is
stateful widget or this state has many
other methods which you can override
like in its state if you want to
initialize something before creating
this widget which means when this screen
is creating before that this method will
be called similarly once you destroy
this screen you can call this disposed
method
so basically there is dispose then there
is did change dependency a lot of other
methods which we will definitely talk
about in future but this is about it and
now this is how our chapter 3 is also
completed and we will move to chapter 4
in the next video
so
so guys so far we have done everything
on a single file which is again a very
big problem with flutter if you will try
to do everything in a single file then
after some time it will be very
difficult to read so in this video we
are gonna see how we can organize this
code so that it looks better and it
gives a better feel right so what we are
gonna do first of all I am going to
create a new chapter
so I'll click here I'll create a new
branch I will call it dev hashtag
chapter 4 and inside this chapter first
of all we will do the refactoring so
guys first of all I don't want this
drawer to be here so this drawer is
actually can have a separate file where
we can write this drawer so I will go
here inside this Lib folder and I will
create a new file I will call it drawer
drawer dot tart and inside this file I
am going to import the same you know
material dot dot package and now I will
copy this code from drawer and try to
paste it there so this is the core I
will just copy it from here
or cut it from here and I will try to
paste it here
but it will not work because you know
this file cannot understand from where
it is starting from where it should end
so rather than just pasting we will
create a new stateless widget because we
our drawer is not changing right now or
we are not doing any runtime change so
that's why this can be a stateless
widget so I can say stateless widget and
I'm going to name it my drawer let's say
so my drawer is here now rather this
container we will return this entire
drawer we will remove this coma from the
end and now it is good to go now rather
then we'll go back to main door dot and
rather than specifying the entire drawer
here I can say my drawer and now I have
to do one more thing
I have to just import it so it's already
imported here as you can see on the top
and now if I just press command s to
save it you will see everything is
working right so everything is smooth so
similarly what we will do we will also
remove this card so what I'm gonna do
guys
this card I'm going to select this card
so this card I have selected till this
braces so fall for this bracket I will
use this and then I will press on this
ball button and there is a something
called extract method and extract widget
so I can extract this widget and once I
extract it it will ask me to give it a
name so that you know you can create a
new widget by itself so we can say
something like on name card okay so name
card widget so we gave this name if you
will see name card widget and if I press
ENTER here so you will see it will be
replaced by name card widget and now we
have a class with name card widget which
extend a stateful widget and it takes
all the properties in the constructor
like my text my controller name
controller and everything here now we
can also make a separate file of this so
we can say name called
widget dot dot and here in this file we
can copy and paste that code so first of
all I will import material dot dot and
then from the main method I am going to
cut this put clasp whole class and I'll
paste it here inside this and this is
looking good and now I'm going to just
import it so I will press command dot or
I enter in Android studio or control dot
in vs code for Windows and command S and
now you can see everything is still the
same everything is working there is no
error or bug and now it's looking much
cleaner just 61 lines of
but guess we can do one more thing we
can remove this entire homepage from
here we can create a separate pages
folder so inside Lib we will create one
more folder this time pages and here we
will create a new file we will call it
home underscore page dot dot and here
also you know we will import material
dot dot and then we can cut this
particular code from here and we can
paste it here okay and this time we will
import the drawer we will import the
name card widget and then the drawer and
we should be good to go
and here in the main dot dot I will
import this home page and yes and we
will remove these two unused imports so
as soon as I do that I need to do a hot
restart and everything will start
working yes everything is same and in
fact if you don't want to do this hot
restart again and again then you can
also remove this material app from here
so we can remove it and we can say
something like here
stateless widget and we can say my app
and we can just remove this material app
from here and we can say something like
this and we can here now in the run app
we can just say my app and that's it
that's the only thing we have to do and
now everything looks the same but the
good thing is like you know everything
is looking like this is just having 99 s
of code or 20 lines of code then the
home page is also just 40 lines of code
drawer is also 30 lines of code and name
card widget is also 4050 lines of course
so this way it will be much more
organized and this test widget test is
also giving us some issue so now I am
gonna just remove home page and I'll now
say again my app and it will fix that
issue as well
so I didn't just gonna remove it and yes
we are good to go guys so this is
something which is very important
organizing your code and in the next
video we are gonna see how we can do
networking in flutter and how we can add
our dependency our first dependency in
the puffs back dot e ml so keep
hey guys so we have done so many things
so far and I'm really glad that you
could make it so far
so we have seen lot of things like how
to use draw how to actually use stateful
widgets how to change the name using
this text field and now we are gonna do
some real world things like you know we
have done all everything so far which is
offline now we want to go to the online
mode as well and by online I mean that
how we will communicate with maybe you
can say with the sower or maybe with the
backend and then we are also as I told
you if we you remember that in the pub
spec dot y ml we add dependencies or
which means that some libraries may be
packages plugins are to talk to native
code as well and to talk to maybe your
back-end so that's what we are gonna do
in this particular video and guys once
our thing again which is very important
is that make sure that you also check
the notes during this course because
there might be few important things or
few things which you definitely want to
take a look so now let me just explain
you once that what we are actually gonna
do so if you are not familiar with this
then I'm just gonna explain you that
what I am talking about actually so if I
do that yeah so if you can see my iPad
here then I'm gonna just explain you
this so basically but what I mean here
is that let's say this is what we have
this screen okay and this is our
computer okay so this is my computer and
let's say this is my computer and we
call it a client okay so when we are
talking about the client which means our
computer which is somewhere here or
let's say in India okay and it wants to
make a request so it's a kind of a
request and it makes it to a server
okay so
somewhere on the cloud and this cloud
does not mean it's up in the air this is
me this just means that this is another
computer which is somewhere else in the
world maybe maybe in Asia maybe in u.s.
anywhere it can be and now this is
making a request and it wants something
from it so what it will send is a
request and what this server will send
to this client will be a response ok so
this is the important part now because
this is this is kind of a communication
which is happening and they have to
follow some protocols now if you will
just think that if you are driving or if
you are going from one place to another
then you have to follow some protocols
you have to follow some rules right so
similarly they have some protocols which
they have to follow and that's what we
called HTTP which means hypertext
Transfer Protocol and using this
protocol only they can communicate so
this is what we are going to use and
then the way they communicate can be in
different forms one of the forms which
is very popular the how the transfer
message is what we called JSON which
means JavaScript object notation and if
you want me to explain it more then you
can just call it like it's it's kind of
this you can say key values payer where
there will be a key let's say name name
is a key and then it will have some
value which is let's say PI 1 is a value
of this name so this is how the actually
communicates so this this is something
which we need to understand and now we
will actually proceed further and now
I'll go to pub spec dot e ml and I'll
add one dependency and that dependency
would be I will go to my website or or
the Chrome browser and I'll write pub
dot tab and here I can search for HTTP
as you can see this is the first package
or you can say library which we will get
HTTP and this is the version I will see
how we can install that so this is how
we can install that so we I just we are
just going to copy it and then
we will paste it inside the pulse
backdoor tml below this line which is
Cupid you know icons and then you will
press command S or you you can just
write flutter packages get and you
should get exit code zero which means
everything worked pretty well and I am
also mask enable the screen cast modes
so that you can see my shortcuts so yeah
this is looking good now and now if I go
back to home page I am using this you
know name card widget and I really don't
need it anymore
so I'm gonna remove this so as well as
I'm gonna remove this single child
scroll view as well because I don't need
any of them so let's remove this child
and now we will see nothing on the
screen technically so I am also gonna
run this application so that we can
check and guess one more thing is they
are like when you are adding any package
or plugin so once you are adding a
plugin which means it has some code
written in Kotlin or maybe an
objective-c or Swift then you have to
restart your app I mean restart from the
scratch which means you have to stop it
if it's running already and then you
need to start it so that your
application can understand about those
plugins or otherwise it will give you
some platform exception but in case of
packages like HTTP or any other package
which is totally written in dart then
you don't have to restart your
application from scratch you can just do
a hot restart so that will also work now
as you can see we have nothing here but
now we are gonna use that HTTP package
to fetch some data ok so what I'm gonna
do um this we don't need anymore so I
can just comment it as of now and Here I
am gonna say that I am going to hit a
URL okay from where we will get the data
so URL is kind of an address which is
similar to your home address right so
every website or every webpage has an
address so here if you'll see we have
this dummy address which is Jason
placeholder dot TP koat.com slash photos
so we are gonna use this address and we
are gonna paste
here so so you can see this HTTP which
is s is for security you can say which
means it has SSL certificate and this is
HTTP which is hypertext Transfer
Protocol which which is the rules which
it needs to follow now I'm also gonna
explain you something about a
synchronous programming very soon just
an idea about it so this is what we have
done right and then we will be waiting
for some response or maybe I should say
some data okay and then here in init
state I can say let's say fetch data
okay so this is the matter method which
we are going to call now fetch data is
not defined as of now and I guess one
more thing is that you can see that I
see these kind of errors right in on
right next to this particular line and
what if you want to see it then you can
go to these problems and here you will
see the same problem but why I am seeing
it here this red one is because of an
extension which is which is a error lens
so if you want you install it and you
can definitely watch my vs code tutorial
on YouTube so that you can get the idea
and now um we have to define this fetch
data method so I am gonna say fetch data
here and now um there are two kinds of
you know communication or operations
which can be done and that's what I'll
explain you next so if we are talking
about that so let me just tell you so
let's say there are two kinds of
operation one is a synchronous so we can
say a sync and second one is sync so
which means synchronous so let's say
guys uh once you go to app is I store ok
so you go to a piece I store so you ask
for a piece alright so when you ask for
a pizza it's not like so there is a guy
this guy a he will take your order
ok so you will go to him he will take
your order he will write it somewhere
and then your pizza will be like it's
preparing right and by that time your
Pisa is preparing this guy a goes to
some other person some random person
here he will take his order as well and
then his pizza will be preparing and
then he will take some others order and
then his pizza will be preparing and as
soon as your pizza will be prepared he
will deliver that pizza to you right and
then again the same process we follow
this is called a synchronous programming
but in case of synchronous it's more
like that it's it's like you are here at
a ticket counter okay and there are many
people in the line a B C D or maybe you
are at an ATM so you will see that once
a we'll be done with the process then
only we can go so which means he will
give him money he will ask for ticket he
will give him ticket back and then only
a will go okay and then it will be done
for B and then it will be done for C so
this is called synchronous programming
okay and when we are dealing with
applications like these so we want to
have experience like a synchronous
programming where user does not want to
wait so maybe he can do something else
while that thing is happening so that's
why we are gonna use our sync here and
I'm gonna make a separate course for
this so you don't have worry about that
that if you don't understand few parts
of it and now what I'm gonna do I'm
going to import so we can remove this
name card widget and I'm going to import
here the HTTP package which we just use
and we can import it as HTTP so now we
can use this HTTP keyword to you know
call all of its method so as you can see
unused import we haven't used it but
here in fetch data we are going to use
it so HTTP dot get so this is there are
various kind of requests which we can
make like get post put and delayed so
those are some of the requests or get
means to get something and post means to
actually create something there
so it needs an URL so we already have a
URL so we are giving that URL now we
want it to be a synchronous so we need
to call it a wait here which means wait
for it until it gives you some data
right and we will store it to a response
which is where arm where is a keyword
which we can use to store a variable and
now once we receive that response we can
print it using rest dot body ok so this
is what we are going to do and now just
- see this debug console I'm gonna do a
hot restart and we got some error that
named controller is not defined and
something like that okay so I am gonna
just uncomment this particular line here
and we are going back here just clean it
out and do a hot restart so you will see
that this URL will definitely give us
some data so this is the data as you can
see this is the rate of each week god ok
and as you can see this is again in the
JSON form which I just described you in
the beginning with the diagram that this
is how we will treat this data ok so now
once we got Jason we need to parse it as
well okay so for parsing JSON parsing we
will use something called another
library which we which we call dart
underscore convert so what it will give
you is it will give you a method called
JSON decode so now we have this data and
we can use this data with this you know
JSON decode and for decoding JSON it
will give us the map map means it will
have a key and value so we need to give
it our source okay so by default the
data which we are getting so you must
have seen this data this is actually a
string we need to convert it to a JSON
object so that's why I'm we are using
JSON decode and we will pass it the re s
dot body so we we will get this data
here and now we can also in the center
here we can also check if this data is
not equal to null so we can check if the
data is not equal to
null then show a container so this
question mark is means conditional
operator we are applying here and then
this colon and otherwise if if it is
null then in the center what you can do
just show a circular progress indicator
so which means this which you will see
so this is not showing this circular
progress indicator which means our data
is known as of no okay but as you can
see we are already receiving some data
and let's try to print that data as well
so print data and what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do a hot restart again because
every time you are doing something in
the energy State you need to hot restart
okay so I am going it and I'm going to
do a hot restart so that it can print
the data and yeah it's printing the data
guys and this time you can see this is
not a string this is this time it's an
object but the problem is that even if
it is printing the data our data is
still null that's why it is showing this
circular progress indicator this is
happening because our UI does not know
that we got the data somehow we have to
tell it that yes we got the data now you
need to refresh your or yourself so as I
told you in previous video whenever you
get this data you have to when you
whenever you want to change the UI you
have to call set state okay and as soon
as I will do it you will see the the
circle is not appearing anymore and now
we have got some data that means this
blank container if I give it a color
then you will see that we actually got
the data so let's say we say color dot
blue so you will just see this blue
screen right so this is fine but this is
now how we want the data we want the
data to be inside the ListView so we
will use list view dot builder okay and
this way what we can do we can specify
an item builder so what item build up
means is that how your items will look
in the ListView and then also we are
going to give it an item count okay that
total how many items will be there so we
can just say data dot length
which means this will be our item count
whatever length of data we are getting
and the for item builder it gives us two
things one is the context which is
actually I'll make a separate content on
this context as well but just for
understanding you can say you will see
this context with every kind of widget
inside this build method as you can see
we are getting this context so context
is basically something which have the
location of your widget okay so it's
kind of like every widget has some
location in the widget tree so this
context is basically aligned to that so
basically what happens is that there is
three trees which you are working on one
is your widget tree then second is
elementary and third is the render tree
so this elementary is associated with
this context and you don't have to go in
detail just make sure right now that you
understand that this contact is kind of
a location of that widget in the widget
tree and then it also gives you index
that what is the index of you know your
particular item and if you know that you
know in programming that everything
starts from zero so this index is also
starts from zero okay and here we can
just say return a list tile okay the
same thing which we used in drawer and
so while this tile because it has
already some inbuilt properties like
leading so for leading we can use
something and we have titles so let's
try to use something like title and we
can use data and then we can pass the
index that for which index we want the
data and then we have to specify a key
so here you will see that we have
multiple keys like album ID ID title URL
and thumbnail URL so I'm going to use
this title so I can say title and now
you will see this is not a sub type or
subtype of widget because it's it's it's
a string okay
but title takes a widget so we will just
copy it and we will remove this and we
will use text here and then we will
paste it and now if you will see then we
have all that
it'll say okay and we have the list view
and this list view dot builder is kind
of a recycler view in Android so which
means it do the caching as well it do
the recycling as well so it actually
carries all the elements which is
visible on the screen if it is not
visible then it does not care about that
okay this is what we have done right now
similarly we will have the subtitle as
well and this time we will use something
called string interpolation which starts
with dollar and we can actually use this
curly braces to give variable to it
let's say data and then index and this
time we can just access the ID so now we
have the ID and you can see seven eight
nine ten you can see four five six seven
and now why I use it use this
interesting interpolation so that I can
write something like ID colon space and
now every element have this ID six seven
eight nine ten and all and the last
thing is that we want in the leading to
use an image so we we will be fetching
image from the network so we can use
image dot network and for this we can
again use data index and this time if
you see we have something called a URL
and Thummim le world so I'm gonna use
URL so you are L and now you will see we
should see the images yes we can see
that and this is looking pretty nice
right so this is what we can do and this
is what we are fetching from the
internet so you don't have to worry
anymore than how to parse JSON how to
fetch data using these things and this
is how we will end this chapter four so
chapter four is completed and in the
next video we will move to chapter five
and we will talk about some interesting
stuff like how to make login page how to
do navigations and all
hey wassup guys and we have done a lot
of things in the last video we actually
saw how to use this package called HTTP
to make Network calls we also face some
data from you can say a dummy server and
then we also saw that how we can use
ListView builder to perform some
operations also I forgot to tell you one
thing in the last video which is that
you can also use grid view to represent
this although the information like this
this this is a very long information so
grid view will not make much sense but
let me just tell you it's very easy to
convert it to a grid view so we could
just replace this ListView with grid
view and then we could use it with grid
view dot builder but then we need to add
one more extra parameter which is grid
delegate so grid delegate takes a sliver
grid delicate sliver itself a very big
topic which we will cover later and but
what it takes is sliver clear delegate
with fixed cross access count which
means how many items you want to show in
one row so cross X is count let's say 2
so 2 items will be shown as you can say
this is now a grid view and if you want
to change it to 3 you can change it and
then there will be 3 items although it
looks pretty bad because of that text we
are using so we are going to switch back
to list view this is just for
understanding purposes and yeah that's
that's what we did now um I'm just gonna
go back and I'm going to start a new
chapter so I'll create a new branch I
will call it there has text chapter 5
and in this chapter guys what we are
going to cover is that how to design a
login page as well as how we'll do the
navigation so for navigation we have
just one pages of no home page so we
need to design a new page quickly so
here in the pages section I will click a
new file I am calling it login
underscore page dot start quickly we are
here and we are going to import material
dot dot and at the same time this is
going to be stateless widget as of now
so I can call it maybe let's
a login page so by default you can start
with stateless widget and then when you
see that you need some kind of state
change then you can directly convert it
to a stateful widget that's how I will
suggest you to proceed and then we can
use a scaffold and this because we
cannot see any changes here because we
are using home page so we can go to over
main dot dot here rather than this home
page we can make it a login page and
then we need to import this login page
so that we can see the changes so now we
are on the login page we can also remove
this debug banner if you want so for
that we can just write here debug show
check mode banner and we can make it
false so you will see that banner is
gone and it's not there anymore
now we will go back to our login page
this is the scaffold here we will again
use app bar so a bar budget and then
title and in the text part we can just
tell it let's say a login page ok and
this is this is fine this is what we
have been seeing ok and in the body what
I'm gonna use I am again going to use a
single child scroll view why because I
want the scrolling to happen if it's a
small screen and then I'm going to take
a column and inside the column I am
going to take some children like you
know how we could have something like a
username or maybe a password so those
are the things which we can have but
case I have already told you about text
field what if I told you this time like
something new so this time I'm gonna
tell you that we can also use something
called a form so form is another widget
which can helpful in collecting like a
dataset ok so let's say if you have
username password or maybe you have a
registration page and you want to
collect all the data and you want to
validate that you want to save that so
you can use form in that case so let me
just tell you how you can use a form so
for that we will convert it to a
stateless to stateful widget what's the
purpose so that we can actually generate
a form key
and even if you don't want to use it
then also we can right now proceed but
in future if you want to change show
something on your screen the login page
then definitely you need it so right now
let's let's have a form key so we can
say a form key so basically this is a
global key okay and this global key
actually takes a form State so form
State and this is our form key and
inside this column we are going to have
all the elements so I can wrap it with a
form so form form is here now if you if
you see if I haven't told you already
then every widget takes up key as I told
you so key is basically it represent
what widget is like I mean this is a
rigid but how you will identify which
widget is this so you can give it a key
let's say PK 1 it can be a local key
object key unique key whatever you want
to give it so that framework identifies
that which frame which particular widget
to rebuild and when ok so we will give
it a form key which we have already
created and using this form key we can
save this form we can validate this a
lot of things we can do and now this
time rather than text field if you want
to apply the form mechanism then you
have to use text form field it's kind of
same but it has some more properties
like you will see it has unsaved which
is important and valid data which is
again important so these are like it
does not have unchanged property or it
has actually it has on changes so it's
it is having everything which text field
have but it has some extra fields as
well so yeah there are lot of things
which maybe you can explore but right
now we cannot so text one field is there
now we can have different you know
controllers like be all earlier hat so
you can say maybe user name controller
so you can use them if you want and if
you want to skip them then also that is
fine as of now it is not actually very
much needed but then it's good to have
them and similarly we can have password
controller and this will be again texted
in controller and as you know we are
using dart too so we can skip this new
keyword so that's why I'm not using this
new cube or otherwise it is the same
thing and here in this text one field
for the controller part I'm going to use
username controller and guys this time
I'm going to show you the user name is
actually having let's say an email ID so
we can have a keyboard type and text
input type dot email address which means
the keyboard which it will open if
you'll click here then it will be of
type of email as you can see at the rate
symbol here so this is what it will do
okay so that's this advantage and then
we can have the decoration as well and I
can call it input decoration and here
for the hint text I will say inter email
okay enter email and then for label text
I can say maybe username just for the
idea and similarly I am going to copy
and paste this another time and this
time I am going to call it password
controller so password controller and
enter password password and then label
text could be password and this is
looking good but if you will enter some
password first of all it should not be
of type email address so I can just say
text so now if you will click here then
you will see there is no add the rate
symbol anymore so that's a good thing
and also we don't want to show the
password by default so we can up secure
this text to true and then you will see
we will have only this dot dot dot okay
and every time you will do a hot hot
reload then you will see you will lose
every character here okay so if I do hot
reload evil
see that we lost actually the data in
the password so for that we need to
actually convert it to a stateful widget
so that we don't lose it if you will now
if you write something here if i do a
control hot reload then you will see
nothing is lost okay so this is again
important thing that's why it I told you
and now it is actually very much stick
to this corners so what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna give some padding to this column
so let's give it a padding of 16 so that
it does not look that bad it's looking
fine now and one more thing we can do
guys is we can actually make it in the
center that's all so we'll be fine and
then we can wrap it with a card as well
so that it takes the only space which is
needed so now we have a card we have
text form field and we can also have a
button so there can be many kind of
button like a flat button raised but an
outline button so there are lot of
buttons even raw material buttons in the
material design guidelines so we are
going to use a raised button which has
some kind of elevation so again I told
you in the beginning as well that every
button has a property called on pressed
so what will happen when you will press
on it right so this is looking cool and
guys we need to give it a child so let's
say text and we can call it sign-in okay
we can also give some color to this
particular button so there is a property
called color we can call it let's say
color start yellow maybe if it looks
fine maybe orange orange will look much
better so orange and for text color
either you can go with black or maybe
you can also say text color as white if
that looks good to you so sign-in is
also there we want to give some space as
well between them so let's give our
space with sized box so size box height
and then maybe 10 let's see if that
looks good even we can give 20 to be
honest because Oh
have a lot of space in this screen and
then here as well and this is looking
good guys
but still it it is not in the center
because our main axis alignment should
be in the center and it's it's not in
the center because we are using single
child scroll views so that's why it's
not in the center if I will remove this
then it will already go to the center
and if you'll see that so here it is
right so we are going to use single
child scroll view anyway and what I'm
gonna show you the another thing is that
we can also wrap this entire stuff so I
am going to copy this single child
scroll view and I want a background
image okay so in the background I want
an image the same image which we used
for that purpose we can use a stack so
stack means means that this is a widget
where there will be items placed one on
the top of another okay so here also it
takes a children and the first element
which we can use his image dot asset and
we can say SH /bg dot jpg this is the
same thing which we have already used
right and now this is the image but we
want it fullscreen so Steph has a
property called fit and this time it
does not take a box fit but it takes
stack fit so we can say expand so it
will expand and then we can call here
the fit as box with dot cover so that it
can cover the entire section right but
this is looking good but at the same
time you will see that this is actually
so if what I can do if I just copy paste
all the code again so it looks but you
know the background is very visible so
it does not look that good right so what
we can do to avoid that so for that if
we I go back to this image then there is
another property called color okay so I
can use color I can use colors dot black
and then with opacity so I can give it a
opposite E of 0.7 and it is actually
like the image is kind of gone
so to actually make it just dark and we
can use something called a blend mode so
color blend mode is there and we can say
blend mode dot darken so now you will
see a darken version of it and it looks
pretty fine to be honest it's not
looking that bad at all and then we can
just wrap this single child scroll view
with another padding so that okay this
card is looking better now and if you
want you can now this push this to
Center and this will be going to the
centers and this Center now we can
remove and yeah so this is everything
which you can do right and now what we
can do when we press on this sign-in
button we can go to actually the home
page so for that how to do the routing
thing we can use a class called
navigator okay so here in the on fresh I
can say navigator now navigator has many
methods like pop pop means going back
push means actually pushing on to
something on the stack so if you want to
understand with our diagram so how we
will do that let's let's just see how it
works so let's say if you have certain
CDs so this is let's say this is
actually not looking like a CD this is a
very bad CD and I'm just gonna remove it
so let's say we have a CD like this and
on the top office there is another CD
and then there is another CD so push
means adding one on the top pop means
actually removing from the top okay and
then pop means removing another one and
then pop means removing another one and
push means adding another one on the top
okay so this is what actually stack do
okay so this is what we are going to do
so we are going to push which means we
want to go to the next screen so push
means going to next screen pop means
going back and it takes about so we can
use a material page route okay and this
material page route takes a builder
builder means it takes a context
and then what visit you want to build so
we want to actually go to this homepage
visit so homepage we can just say and
then we need to import this homepage
because it does not understand what is
homepage so we can import library
homepage dot dot so pages slash homepage
dot dot so here we are we can remove
this main dot dot and now if I will
click on this sign-in button then it
will take us to the home page home page
right but if I will press this back
button now then we can go back to our
home page which we won't be needed maybe
in future because once we are like
crossing this login page then we don't
want to come back and ten let someone
press the logout button right so that's
fine now what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna show you the use of the form
okay so how we could use the form so we
could use our form key which we created
so form key and we could use the current
state from that so current state is what
is the state of the form I mean what
data you have entered what is its state
and then we could say save very date and
everything okay
so we could say validate it could
believe it validate all the fields for
us and we could say save let's say we
could say validate what would with what
would happen if we will call it like
validate so it will go to this text form
field and it will check what's happening
on the validate so we haven't
implemented it so nothing will work so
we can just say validator and we can do
some operations here okay and it will
check that similarly it will go to the
second form field and it can check the
validator here as well and by comparing
all of them then it will see if
everything is true or not then only it
will give us so validate if you see it
gives us a boolean which means
everything was true or not
if not then do something if yes then do
something else so it's again something
which you can right now skip so this is
how you will understand that push means
going back to going to homepage and
let's say
in the homepage let's say we are here
and though in the action bar which is AB
bar we can have some actions as well and
this time I'm gonna talk about a new
widget which is icon button so in the
icon button I could say I have an icon
so I can use icons library so I can
start let's say logout which means exit
to app something like this and then F
because it's a button so it is also
needed to have an on pressed button okay
and this time I could say something like
navigator dot pop so that it can go back
to that screen so if I press here now it
will take me back to the login page and
in fact we can again make it more easy
like this is looking a like kind of lot
of work so what we can do in the login
page we can give it a static Const
string a route name okay
so basically we can name this particular
route so we can say let's say slash
login so this is our route similarly we
can give it to home page but right now
we don't need it so in the main dot dot
for home we have already specified login
page right and then we can have another
property which we call the routes and it
takes a map so basically we have to say
what is the route name and where it will
go so we can use login page dot route
name and where it goes we can use
context to define that it goes to login
page okay similarly we can have the same
thing for home page ok so I'm going to
just copy this thing from here and I am
going to paste it to this particular
home page as well and we can call it
slash home ok
and in the main dot dot we can just copy
this and I am doing it with control D by
the way so home page and we can say home
page and now guys going to login page we
actually so basically if you want to
transfer some data from here to this
page then in the constructor of home
page you can pass some data right but
let's say if you don't want to pass a
data and if you want to have some simple
way to run it some some clean way to
write it then we can use something
called a navigator dot push named which
means we can pass the name of that
particular route and we can say home
page dot route name okay and now this
will perform the same thing this is much
cleaner and now if I click here then
also it will go to this particular page
now if I will just you know remove this
application from this stack and then I
try to go back then also it will take me
to the login screen also it is right now
it will not work because we are using
virtual machine so it it does not
understand what was there in the last
time but if I do a hot restart or maybe
file try to restart this application it
will actually start from the login page
which we don't want and in the next
video we will see that how actually we
can logged in the user and whenever he
will actually run this application so if
I run this application right now so it
will launch the login screen but once
the user is logged in we don't want to
actually take him back to the login
screen so that's why we are going to use
something called shared preferences in
the next video and by the time I'm just
gonna show you once if I will run this
application again then you are going to
see a login screen ok and not the home
screen so every time it will take you to
the login screen which we don't want ok
so that's this you might have seen in
most of the applications so as you can
say we are back to the login page and
the next video we will definitely check
it how we
hey guys so uh we have seen a lot of
things again and this time we have seen
this login page where we have this form
where we have username and password and
then there's a button which is a race
button and when we click on it it goes
to the next screen what our application
does not know how to actually store this
state which is like you know a
persistent state and we can use
something like shared preference to
store this persistent state in keys and
values and this thing will be a
synchronous as well so we actually don't
know how to use it yet right so for that
what we are going to use we are going to
go to pub dot dev and here I can write
you know shared preferences and we feel
click here then this this is the shared
preferences package and this is now on
it's not just a packet it's actually a
plugin so which means there is some code
which is written in for Android it is
written maybe it is written in Cortland
for IIST maybe it is written in
objective-c or Swift
similarly on Android it can it might be
written in Java as well and for web it
might be having something else let's say
JavaScript and some other things so it
uses local storage there so yeah this is
actually something which we are going to
use and for that we have to go to this
installing section and then we can add
this dependency and guess this is
probably the last course of this
particular series and pardon me this is
probably the last video of this series
and they can be more videos I don't in
the future for sure and the best part is
that we will be updating this course
regularly so shared preferences zero
point five point six plus one I guess
let me just see that yeah zero point
five point six plus one exit code zero
which means it is successful and as I
told you whenever you will add a plug-in
then you have to actually restart your
application otherwise you will get an
expansion exception like you know
platform exception that this is some
plug-in missing exception
and something like that so now we are
running this application again we are
having two pages one is the login page
another one is the home page and we have
added shared preferences now inside the
Lib we can have something like a new
folder and we can call it utils and
inside this utils we can have a new file
called constant constant dot dot okay
and by the time it is running we can
have a class here we can called it
constants and if it can constants okay
this is looking good now inside this
class we can have a static reference to
our shared preference so shared
preference and preference so prefs we
can just call it perhaps so that we
don't want to like you know this is kind
of a singleton so if it's a singleton
that it we don't want to create a new
instance of it so that's why it's
singleton so we can just store a static
reference to this and now I will go to
my main dot dot and this time what I am
gonna do here here because we want to
store it or the shared reference and we
need to use the await keyword so I'm
going to first of all make it a future
and then I'm going to add a a
synchronous like this particular keyword
here and then we have to do something
like you know widget binding so there is
something called widget flutter binding
so it has a method which we have to call
ensure initialize that means make sure
that everything is initialized and then
we can use our constants dot so we need
to import it as well dot prefs and we
can use now await keyword and we can use
shared preferences dot get instance so
by this we will get the instance of the
shared preference whatever instance it
is having because it's it's always going
to have single instance and that's why
it's a single
class if you'll go here you will see
that this is actually a singleton class
right so um this makes sense to me now
what I'm gonna do I'm going to come back
here and when I'm doing the login page I
am going to use before actually doing
the navigation I am going to use this
constant okay dot let me just import it
dot prefs dot set and we have set string
set in set bull so for this simple data
types you can use shared preferences so
for set Bowl we will use and the key I
am gonna say is logged in okay and the
value I'm gonna say is true that which
which means is that logged in is not
true so what we can do now if I do if I
go to sign-in and if I click here what
nothing is working that's that's weird
let's just see why it's not working oh
we got an error that this constant dot
prefs it does not understand that so
which means we have to restart our
application because we did some changes
in the main dot dot and now if I click
on the sign-in button then you see I
came to this homepage right but if I do
a hot restart again then it will take me
back to the login page which write which
I don't want because I just saved this
particular property that if it is logged
in which means true then actually I
don't want to come back to home screen
how we can do that so in the main dot
dot you can see in the home part we are
using login page right so what we will
do here we will say just use my gone
start perhaps and get me the boolean
which is which is what is the key logged
in okay and if it is true by default it
will be false but if it is true then
take me to home page okay but if it is
false then take me to login page okay so
this is after or this if we say this
then now you can see we are back to ah
this homepage and now even if I do a hot
restart then also it will be always
having me on the home page but if I
press the back button this time then it
will just you know remove this app from
this stack and that's that's what I
always wanted but there's one more thing
we can do guys in the login page we can
actually replace this okay
so rather than push named we can
actually replace it so that every time
when we so we could say something like
push replacement named which means it
will be removed from the stack this
login page so that there is no chance of
coming back to this screen and now we
have to actually run it again because
and this time when we will run it so
because our logged in is true so it
should take us to the home page rather
than login page right so let's see how
that goes and I hope and I just don't
hope I am sure that it will work like
what we want so one more thing is guys
that you can use string integer boolean
most of the time and then also you can
use a list as well but you have to then
use something like JSON in code to like
convert it to a string and then maybe
you can save it and this is for small
small variables and as you can see we
are now on the home page rather than
login page and now what you will see
that how we can now go back to home page
because you just told us that it is not
true how to make it false right so in
the home page when the person is
actually you know this time this
navigator dot pop will not work so when
the person let's say is trying to log
out so we could say constants dot prefs
dot set bool and this time in the key
part again I'm gonna say the same key
logged in and this time the value I'm
gonna give is false so make it false
okay and
then if now you'll press on it because
it's it's having this navigator dot pop
let me just open the debug console as
well if I click here then you will see
it will pop this home screen so now we
have no screen so that's what we don't
want so now we will do a hot restart and
this time we will go to login page and
now you will fill some data here
whatever you want to fill there's no
validation as of now and that's not this
in the scope of this particular course
so now if I press sign in this is fine
but now this is actually we are using
push replacement so if now you will
press back button then it will not take
you back to the login screen but if you
might have missed this you know push
replacement thing then it will take you
back to the home screen in iOS there is
no back button button and right there is
definitely is so we need to be very
careful and rather this rather than this
navigator dot pop we can again use
navigator dot push replacement named
okay so that and I'm going to show you
if I go to let's say if I just go to
using this push named I go to this login
page let's say login page dot route name
then if I will just you know try to
press this login button then it will
take us to this login page but if I will
press back here then you can see we are
back to this home page so that's what we
don't want so that's why I told you to
use here push replacement named okay and
there is a whole course which is coming
for this routing thing there will be lot
of things which you will be learning so
now if I press here then you can see we
came back to login page but now if I
will press this back button then you
know we go we went to some other
application because it's it's just a
debug application so that's what you can
do guys and now this is how we will end
over this particular course and for the
time being and maybe there will be in
future there can be more videos added to
it so if you are watching it after some
time let's say if there are more videos
next to it and it's
so great thing and now we are actually
completing Chapter five at least for
this particular course and also let me
know in the comments that what you feel
about this course what should be
improved so there will be the good part
is that if you have paid for this course
there will be a lot of improvements
happening all around during this course
or even in the next courses and I hope
that you enjoyed this particular series
and course where you learned the
essential things which you definitely
need to learn about fluid or and then
now you can move ahead you can make your
applications and then you can also take
real-world course where we will make a
real-world application using flutter you
can take flutter with firebase course
which should be up very soon so yeah
thank you so much guys for joining and
as you know there is this source code
you can access this is already in the
notes you can check it out and I hope
that there are so many apps which you
can build using these practices which I
have told you there are many things
which can be improved it's not like
these things cannot be improved but yeah
you will learn it by the time so thanks
guys for watching and see in the neck
welcome back guys and I hope that you
have already finished your flutter
essential course but because you are a
part of my choir school so there are
some extra classes and in this classes
we are going to cover a few more awesome
stuff about flutter which in case if you
want you can skip but if you if you'll
use them then it will make you more
productive as a flora developer so
that's why I thought about covering them
and in these few videos we will see
these awesome things so in the first
video we are going to talk about
something called a future builder and
how it can help us so now what I'm gonna
do as you can see I have changed my
branch to Deb hashtag extra class so
this is the branch which we will use for
extra classes and before proceeding I'm
going to have a minor change here so in
the Lib folder or I am going to create
another folder first of all that will be
widgets and then I'm going to move this
drawer to this widgets and then this
name card widget as well and now our
home page is going to be angry because
the import does not work anymore and I
am also going to just import a new
relative path you can see and also guys
there are nodes with every lecture or
with every video when you will just
slide it down so please make sure that
you are also at least watching those
nodes because it can have some extra
information which will definitely help
you in your flutter journey so yeah just
to make sure because you have already
finished if you haven't seen those nodes
then definitely you are missing
something so now when we are talking
about this home page let's create
another page here and we are going to
name it let's say home page with future
builder so FB dot dot okay and I'm going
to just paste my home page exactly like
that here as well and just going to name
it to something else so I'm going to
press f2 and home page FB which means
future builder
and home FB let's say and now in the
main dot dot I'm just going to change it
from home page to home page FB so this
is just for reference what and how it
will look when in case of future build
up and one more thing which you might
have noticed is that I am using this
time the iOS simulator just to make sure
that everything works on iOS as well and
now we are here in the home page with FB
and as you can see we are using a
stateful widget we have this method here
fetch data which is a an asynchronous
method and which means it returns a
future okay although we are not
returning it anything here but if we
will write something like this then also
it means the same thing and if you
remember in the main dot dot we actually
added this future keyword because we
have to use this a synchronous keyword
and why because we were awaiting for our
shared preference to get the instance so
that's what what we are doing here and
now talking about future builder is guys
when you are dealing with this future or
when you are interacting with this
future then future builder is going to
give you some snapshots and based on
your snapshot you can build the UI or
the UI will rebuild itself based on
those snapshots and then what will
happen we don't have to use this set
state manually we don't even have to
init our state like we can totally make
it a stateless widget in that case so
let me just show you how that will work
so what I'm going to do here this body
part I am actually going to remove
entirely and rather than anything else I
am going to use something called a
future builder and now this future
builder actually takes few parameters
let's say future so future means you
have to say what will be the future so
future is our this fetch data because it
is returning a future
so I can simply say here fetch data ok
and this is my future and also guys um
we can see here that it takes a builder
as well
so builder is supposed to give us the
context as well as the snapshot and then
it will be also a sync snapshot as you
can see here if you will see builder
here then you will see a sync snapshot
which we are gonna get with this and
then we have to and there is one more
thing which is initial data if you have
some initial data you can provide it
otherwise you can just leave it like
this and now snapshot has many things
like if we want to explore it then we
will say snapshot has it has this
property called has data whether it has
data or not then data what is the data
and has error whether it has error or
not then connection state that what is
the status of your connection and if it
has any error or required data so these
are some properties so I am going to
have here a switch case where I am going
to check the connection States okay
so switch case so switch and what we are
going to like check here which will be
snapshot dot connection state ok and for
every connection state we are going to
have some wizard drawing ok
so first case will be if the connection
state is a nun which means nothing is
happening technically so we will return
a Center a child and we will say in the
text nothing is fetched nothing is fast
or you can say fetch something ok
because it's actually doing nothing so
fetch something so this is kind of an
instruction which we are giving and
let's say if the case is not this but
the case is connection state dot active
so if it is active then we will do
nothing and we will wait for another
connection state and that connection
state can be waiting so if it is waiting
guys so what we can do we can just copy
this particular piece of code and we can
just return rather than text
we can return circular progress
indicator which we actually returned
earlier as well so that's what we are
going to do and then there can be one
more connection state dot let's say done
so if everything is done then what we
are going to say is let's say if
snapshot dot has error if it has error
then we can just copy this particular
text and can say that some error
occurred so all the cases can be covered
here with this future builder and if
there are no errors here then we can
return our list view dot builder so we
can go to home page we can copy our list
view dot builder and let's try to put it
here and yes it looks good to go and
this is showing that it is a dead code
why okay so we have to apply this okay
one second guys so we have to apply this
outside of this has error block okay so
now if you will see on the screen here
then maybe if I do a hot restart okay so
now it's not not working as of now as
you can see that even if we restarted
the application nothing worked because
we don't have to actually use this set
state here rather we need to return the
data which we are getting so returned
data so that we can return the future so
this data is actually giving us a map
values so we can also say map here it's
optional if you will avoid it it will
give some dynamic value and or yes so
it's giving some dynamic value if I say
nothing here which means some dynamic
value which is actually this data will
you then you can see we got the same
result right and if I do a hot restart
now you will see that it will show some
indicator and then this right and let's
say if you want to see some exception if
you is let's say by default or by
mistake you actually got some wrong URL
then you will see that it will show you
let me just do a hot restart
so that this UI can be reflected and you
can see we got some error occurred
because this is a wrong URL and we
cannot get some data and let's say if
how you will see that if connection
state is none is actually you can make
this future as null and then there will
be no connection state so we should see
something like fetch something so in
that case we can change the icon here
okay to refresh and when we are pressing
this button then we can actually enable
a flag by which you can do a set state
and it can fetch some data here okay
so we will basically replace this null
with the flash data and then we will get
some data so this is how future builder
works I hope that you caught the idea
that how it works and it can be very
useful right because you don't have to
like you can check things like this you
don't have to apply so many files you
don't have to check whether this is
something where if you are if your URL
is correct or not and guys now because
there is no need of using this stateful
widget because we are not doing set
state anywhere so what you can do you
can totally remove everything like we
can remove this we can you know remove
this and we can in fact remove this
variable data from here and we can just
say we're data and we can also move this
URL to here and we can make it final as
well we can make it final earlier as
well and now guys what I'm going to do I
am going to make it a stateless widget
and you can just see why stateless
widget because it's not like a stateful
widget will harm you or something but
that is totally fine if so there can be
lesser lines of code so that's the only
difference and now this is a stateless
widget guys and now it's Inc data at
length okay so one more thing which we
had to make right was we miss something
that this data is not this data which we
are returning from here so we have to
replace it with
snapshot dot data okay because that is
the data actually we were also doing the
Unity State so that way that's why it
was working otherwise it cannot work now
and now we are all done and now you will
see that we got the data everything is
fine now let's do a hot restart again
and this is a stateless widget now and
now we are even performing more things
like you know we are showing this some
error occurred and showing this Phet
something then also if you see the lines
of code then it's just 74 and in this
case it was 79 but it was not doing that
much task right so that is the
difference and this is how future
builder can help you and it makes code
looks much more cleaner and yeah it can
be really helpful so I hope you enjoyed
this and in the next particular lecture
we will talk about stream builder so
just keep watching
hey guys I hope that you are enjoying
the extra classes and we just finished
future builder and I hope that you
enjoyed that part of the video because
that can be really helpful and when you
will make some real-world applications
okay now coming to the next thing is a
stream builder so before that let me
just commit this and we can say future
builder completed and also guys check
out the nodes as well so now what we are
going to do let's so create one more
page here and this time we can say home
page with SB which means stream builder
dot dot and what I'm gonna do I'm going
to just copy this entire thing from here
to this particular place and this time
I'm just going to rename it from FB to
SB okay
which means stream builder and yes
that's this that's most of it
and now what I'm gonna do guys rather
than this future builder so I'll go to
main dot dot first and I am going to say
this time home page SB okay and rather
than this okay a future builder I am
going to call it a stream builder and
what will be the difference so
everything remains the same but the only
thing is that it takes a stream okay no
future so now can I provide fetch data
here you might be wondering if yes then
why and why stream builder so yes we can
not provide this data so fetch data the
purpose of fetch data was to return a
future and for that we had future
builder but let's say if you're using
firebase or maybe your back-end is
returning stream so what is a strange
stream is kind of you can say a flow of
data let's say there's a pipe and inside
that pipe you know you are inserting
some kind of data so that's what you can
call a stream and that's that's what you
can call a stream builder and let me
just demonstrate that to you
so you might be wondering what is the
stream so basically what is the stream
is stream is actually let's say if you
have a pipe here okay and this pipe is
where you can actually insert some data
so it's a flow of data so let's say
first it will insert one here then there
will be another flow when it will insert
two here then another insertion three
four five so basically it's what we
called sinking in stream so which means
inputting some data so there is a flow
of data so it's it's not like at one
time there is no like it in future there
is all the data coming at one time but
in stream the rate occurs so that's
that's why it's called a stream so this
is basically called sinking and when we
will output this data then we will call
it streaming so yes that's that's what
stringbuilder is all about and now we
don't have anything like a stream here
so let's make a stream so let's say we
can say stream and it can in return may
be a list of integer okay and get stream
we can call it and okay what may be like
what we want to return here that's the
question now so we can return something
like let's say a data and we can use
something like let's say we copy this
particular thing from here and we have
this method here from I tribal and use
assert some elements okay so we can have
some elements let's say we can say list
end I am gonna just copy it from here
and thought generate and I can give some
length let's say 20 and for every index
I can say some item okay one second guys
so I can say item item and then the
index so maybe something like this yes
and then why it's showing me error okay
so basically we need integers so why am
you even using it's in here so let's
call it string and here also let's call
it string string so now we will return
this data here so return data and now
rather than returning this or using this
fetch data I will say fetch what was
that cat stream okay so cat and stream
and that's the only thing which you have
to do so string is not a subtype of type
int of index that's what it is saying to
us and it does not have these properties
so guys I'm going to remove these things
first and rather than in title I am just
going to say whatever here if the index
just show me that and you can see we
have item 0 to 19 which means 20 items
and that's how streamed builder kind of
works ok if you will provide the null
here then also it will say the same
thing as you can see fetch something and
get stream if you will do a hot restart
then it will show you and because our
data is already with us all the time so
that's why it could not show you this
circular progress indicator so this is
how you will deal with the streams and
some in the real world course I'll show
you how to actually are even in the
firebase we will show you that how you
can use the streams of it stream
builders and firebase so I hope you
enjoyed this video and I am going to
just complete this thing as stream
builder completed so I hope you got the
idea guys so it's it's a normal flow of
data which you will see with the streams
and yeah that's it so I hope you enjoyed
this video and
[Music]